ich bin am Wachtmeister Simona Thomas
von die Villa Pioniere wir sind heute da
in Hermagor in Kärnten bei der
Veranstaltung her und durch und die
nehme ich da jetzt mit
und zeige euch was es bei den Fehler
binäre für Jobmöglichkeiten gibt
das haben wir jetzt bei der
kampfmittelabwehr und der Kommandant
sorgt uns jetzt was ist das
Möglichkeiten gibt also bei uns im
Bereich der Kampfmittel Beseitigung
kampfmittelabwehr besteht die
Möglichkeit zu arbeiten entweder als
Minensucher oder dann in weiterer Folge
als Kampfmittel beseitiger und dann
weiter Stufe in der höchsten Stufe als
Hand entschärfer wir sind die
Möglichkeiten wir bieten die Möglichkeit
im Inland und im Ausland zu arbeiten
wobei unsere Haupttätigkeiten im Ausland
zu finden sind
für Jobmöglichkeiten gibt
werden als Panzerfahrer
als Panzer kann als Sportschütze und da
ist Mechaniker das sind die vier gewesen
die Leute die Bedienung stellen bei
diesen Bergepanzer und die Menschen zu
deinem Frieden können wir Berge Aktionen
durchführen und die vier Personen sind
eigentlich
damit wir unsere fehlerhafinäre am
Wasser schnell zu die Einsätze bringen
haben wir da unser sturmboot und er sagt
uns jetzt was man dafür Jobmöglichkeiten
haben bei uns am Wasser dazu gibt es
zwei Möglichkeiten entweder man ist
Bootsführer oder man ist dauerhaft
so wir sind jetzt doppelte Taucher weil
die Pioniere sind nicht nur am Wasser
sondern unter Wasser im Einsatz was
macht eigentlich
[Musik]
unterwegs und haben wir große
spektromaten aufgenommen
schneiden schweißen und Bergen von von
Objekten und das ist eigentlich der
unser Hauptaufgabe
als weitere Station haben wir da jetzt
die 76 Meter tonnenkran und du sagst uns
da jetzt bitte noch die beruflichen
Möglichkeiten was ja anbieten könnt bei
uns haben wir die berufliche Möglichkeit
im Rahmen der Kader präsenzeinheit mit
dem 76 Meter tonnenkran zum Beispiel im
Ausland bei feldlagerbau oder auch im
Inland Abbau Tätigkeiten durchzuführen
ebenso machen wir mit diesen Kran
Katastropheneinsätze Reinigen von
Verklausungen oder andere oder
Brückenbau das nächste was wir
anzubieten haben sind Jobs als
LKW-Fahrer im Rahmen der KPE normaler
LKW oder auch Anhänger oder haarklider
Transporte ebenso bieten wir an
pioniermaschine in der
Nähmaschine Fahrer vom kleinen 1,6
Tonnen Bagger bis zum großen 20 Tonnen
Bagger oder Radlader auf einer kleinen
Klasse bis zur großen klasse
machen kann wenn ihr ihn berufliche
Herausforderung sucht euch hier und wagt
den Karriere Sprung